welcome to this video playing Grand
Master cortex on forgot about the name
Darwin coolio zibbic from rica croatia
so I went for Kings in yellow is playing
the age 3 line that are also played
numerous times here on icc the Earl in
Bishop e3 is not as popular as it was
years ago still are playable line of
course they very often play with Bishop
g5 nowadays
not quite sure what White's move here 92
g3 many possible ways to play at least
he's not playing instantly ok I want to
prepare a five year okay he's
concentrating on the queenside try to
prove that my night is offside on a six
yeah this is true probably it's not
particularly well placed well I need to
get counter play here and so is really
am putting all the eggs in one basket on
the queenside Knight f6 m-maybe pressure
rising you for the natural move 92 is
not on because of f4 so is just is just
sacrificing okay just giving away you
for maybe you can do that
ok so f4 is nonsense ok I need to
probably take on your phone question is
them with the night over the pond
okay i don't i don't really know how to
hard to assess okay if I go Bishop f5 he
has got g4 are also the c6 idea which is
a problem anyway c6 trying to play
against the night okay what about the
move like Bishop to h6 he's probably
playing edge form just not not
particularly nice maybe I should come on
let's do that reroute this piece to f6
try i need to make sure not to fall
hopelessly behind on the clock
oh now I didn't didn't take that into
account
hmm now that's a problem
hmm Kim
yeah why this white is just better am I
overlooked c6 I white was better anyway
but this is some even more uncomfortable
than I originally thought not sure about
this move what is he doing just trying
to take it okay i have c 6am rook takes
rook takes and so on then c6 oops oh ah
funny Mouse lip okay black resigned I
was here I was grabbing this the Queen
and I wanted to move it back then I went
a bit forward I just wanted to put it
back and played queen before I wanted to
go here white is white is just clearly
better here it's maybe a is it a winner
already yeah probably the strategical
winner this is just a terrible piece I
have six and he's just much better yeah
I had overlooked this c6 idea and white
is better anyway with his better pieces
not quite sure how to how to play this
this was interesting this a three
approach so here and then rook see one
yeah maybe Knight f6 wasn't to the right
way to play here I mean this is still
I'm around something like a theoretical
position
so much shouldn't be M shouldn't be a
disaster for black hmm John maybe maybe
I should take only form I'm not sure
yeah with the song isn't this looks
rather nice for white or Pierre played
this deeply just played c5 yeah the
computer wants to play Bishop h6 but I
didn't see the point after after h4 yeah
maybe this is still the way to go now it
just looks it just looks ugly
yeah this is just not a good position
the night on a six he's got this idea
and he will get get a nice piece on you
for so this wasn't wasn't the way to go
maybe maybe this is somewhat better yeah
but still yeah it's just not a good
position what can you do probably
something else here yeah this is just
the matter of those sir sharp openings
like the Kings in yet once in a while if
you played as black and you don't really
know all the ins and outs someone is
playing in a very principled manner
sometimes so with a line that they have
prepared beforehand and if you don't hit
the right moves exactly then you just
you just swiped out swiped out wiped out
this already was really ugly yeah this
is just just very ugly this position
neither computer points out this
actually had the I said you fought him
maybe even that is possible so trap
piece computer says white is winning but
this is something that the human is not
so easily playing it you have a very
open king but it's plus 3 according to
the comp take this actually helped me a
bit that he didn't take on d6 but this
is just just so ugly
yeah this was a good move I was hoping
of course on that little trick and black
is ok again but ok played this one then
I hate this mouse slip it's a it's just
just ugly I mean maybe maybe we can play
this one being a bit more active but
something like that I can never
exchanged Queen this is just just
terrible alright thanks for watching